OU>>> INHEEW GUIDAC IS N RECOMM
INEGE COUNTR
RI THAN
APPLIES TO THE MIT
COOSE COUNTRY.
D  SCHOOLSLD WEASKF  JSERENT
TAKING LEGAL ACTION TO BLOCK ANY
SK MANDATES INED NOW BKELLY FOR
MOM LELAWSUIT, AND
E ATTORNEY.
IN
USLLR REACTIONE
HEARD TODAY FROM THE CDC.
LAW THE COVI
REEMT
CIBLSK
KIDS GOING BACK TO
ACT BECAUSY EXECUTIVE EMERGENC
AND THE EMOT HOLOGICA A
THHALF OIDS, SC MYLDAN SN
GREATLY OUTWEIGHS T
THON
MAS
A ASE E THE
AD OF TH
TT
IS, DTHE
EIHOCEDREN T
T SWE
CT TYPON I, PLEA.HAT MATHE SPREE
NKS G ATT  I NEW JERSES.THINK W.
IF HAVINONSKS WORKR NO
ECAUSEE KN ST
S WORK.
LYLE THIS.YOU BRT  SO TELL ME YE
OFHAT LD O
MASKS SHOULD NOT BE MANDATEDOR H
WORK?THE FOLLOW-UP THEN I DO TOO
THT E STARTING WITH,
WELL, MAYBE THE MASK
MAYBE IT DOEK THE F WHAT YOU HA
EN HAVE TO AGREE O
D,
EAUS THETH
--
>> WE LIVE I DECTORS IN COMS AT
>> YES.
DE>> LET M.
IT SHOULD ISSUST AND LEGISLATURP
HAOVATD TS BASEDON FORN DOCTORSN
WORKS. THESERE UNKNOWNDOCTORS, .
Y NOT.S THO MAKE RULES ON ICHEA.
- MASSACHUSELOWS THE
>> -- DESI V TBEEN DISCREDITED S
JACOBSON DECISION.WANT TO LEARN
ON ME.
YOY YOU CULE TICE  DIVIDERS.T W
ALBLE?SO RIDE SOCIAL.W DO YOU SS
AND PLASD IVEDOCIAL
OBVIOUSLY IT DK.
AND Y TIME CAVOW
DO THIS TGH
CONG A STATE LEGISRENOT THROUGHR